coup de coeur d'un gâteau peau qui est
très présente ce soir je n'ai jamais
voulu s'y présentent leur démission
mais ce cas là c'est alors qu'elle vient
de perdre son mari elle est courageuse
c'est vrai qu'à vous êtes extrêmement
hypocrite parce que c'est vous qui avez
valider cette théorie moss et pour tout
deux très jeunes ont dit la vérité nos
recettes va extrêmement bien franchement
non mais vraiment il ya un délire quoi
allez-y alors ça mienne ils s'en foutent
un ânon ou sans appel c'est retenue
j'appelle ça un déguisement
[Rires]
je t'aime moi toi ouais donc chez nous
ça fait 15 jours qu'on leur tirait le
sapin alors et c'est wasquehal et moules
pourtant tient
[Applaudissements]
la chaussure enguirlandé web
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parlant de sa poche quand tu as une
épine dans le pied
[Applaudissements]
là bas il m'a dit si on était plus drôle
ailleurs que ce n'est pas ça c'est le
mot benjamin voilà merci